la diplomacia ha vuelto con esta frase
fuerte joe biden resumió su primer
discurso de política exterior en primer
lugar el nuevo inquilino de la casa
blanca hizo varios anuncios que
revierten decisiones de la pasada
administración
by then confirmó que dejara de apoyar
las operaciones ofensiva de arabia
saudita en yemen un conflicto que ha
generado una catástrofe humanitaria sin
precedentes también anunció que detendrá
la retirada parcial de las tropas que
tienen base en alemania y aumentó la
cuota anual de refugiados en su país
hasta un máximo histórico
este decreto nos permitirá aumentar el
número de admisiones de refugiados a
125.000 para el primer año fiscal
completo de la administración by del
harris
por otra parte el presidente baiden
mostró su determinación de contrarrestar
a china y rúsia acusando a su predecesor
de haber sido débil en particular con el
presidente ruso
el liderazgo estadounidense debe hacer
frente a este nuevo momento de
autoritarismo creciente que incluye las
crecientes ambiciones de china de
rivalizar con eeuu y la determinación de
rusia de dañar y perturbar nuestra
democracia sin embargo no renunció al
diálogo con ambas potencias desde el
kremlin reaccionaron diciendo que la
retórica de bailén es muy agresiva por
último el mandatario se refirió al golpe
de estado en mianmar
el ejército birmano debe renunciar al
poder que ha tomado y liberar a los
abogados activistas y funcionarios que
ha venido en un amplio discurso que puso
claridad sobre la posición que tendrá el
gobierno estadounidense como mínimo en
los próximos cuatro años